seid ihr bereit für die leckersten
chorus schnitten der welt ich liebte
es über alles und ich habe mir gedacht warum macht
ich einfach nicht schnitten raus also
lasst uns direkt starten kommt mit
für dieses geniale rezept werde ich jetzt eine
cheesecake masse zusammenrühren und zwar nämlich
der doppelrahm frischkäse ich bin nehme am
liebsten philadelphia der geschmeckt halt salzarm
aber ihr könnt auch gerne mal in die kommentare
schreiben ob ihr lieblings frischkäse habt und da
rühre ich da sahne zucker und vanilleextrakt dazu leute vanilleextrakt ist der
geschmacksträger hier im rezept später kommt auch
noch Zimt dazu weil Churros werden ja später in zimtzucker
gewälzt aber ich möchte zimt noch nicht
im teig haben der kommt gleich erst zum einsatz
ich habe das ganze jetzt in einem
schneebesen verrührt aber auch
nur kurz also das war 10 15 sekundenrüht
nicht zu lange damit der frischkäse
nicht flüssig wird denn sonst ärgert
ihr euch leute das möchte ich nicht und ist
es viel vanille ja es ist viel vanille aber
ohne vanille macht das ganze rezept keinen
sinn und es schmeckt so gut hier sieht man auch
richtig diese vanille pünktchen sarah kannst du mal zoomen
das sind meine vanille pünktchen genau so muss das aussehen
so ich mache jetzt noch zwei zutaten rein
und zwar speisestärke brauchen wir für die
konsistenz ich sieb die speisestärke auf
jeden fall noch mal damit da nachher keine
klümpchen entstehen und dann kommen noch
zwei eier dazu und die ganzen mengenangaben die
schreibe ich euch wie immer unten in die infobox
in tal geht einmal kurz seite legen hier
brauchen wir gleich wieder ich habe jetzt
auch schon zimt und zucker miteinander
verrührt das brauchen wir nämlich jetzt
und was wir auch benötigen ist dieser kurs
ort ihr seht einen fertigen teig leberkäs
kitchen aber dieses rezept durch umhauen
ist und einfach so praktisch und einfach
wie möglich sein und nein ich finde persönlich
ist lohnt sich nicht jetzt ein croissant kann
zu kneten und nehmen dafür eben diesen
aus dem wo er bisher aus dem kühlregal
genau und jetzt einfach öffentlich mache so
dass ein teil unten auf dem boden kommt dann
kommt sie im zucker drauf und dann kommt
denn der andere teil quasi nochmal on top
übrigens dieser teig dieser knack und backtag
den gebrauch von verschiedenen firmen der
kommt immer in so einer super langen forma
sie rollt den außenminister ist halt super
lang und wir wollen das ja ein bisschen anders
geformt haben daher in der mitte einfach einmal
durchschneiden mit dem messer und wenn ihr
das dann so übereinander legt dann habt ihr
eigentlich die perfekten maße ich nehme jetzt
hier meinen verstellbaren back rahmen aus dem
shop verlinke ich euch unten in der infobox
und habe jetzt hier auch mein backblech mit
backpapier dieses backblech ist auch aus dem
shop das ist das super gerade ist also wenn
ihr so ein gewölbtes habt dann passt bitte
auch nicht dass ihr euch ärgert dadurch dass
durch die wölbung der cheesecake masse heraus
fließt das wäre nicht so schön und jetzt ganz
easy zimt zucker einfach hier auf dem
backpapier verteilen und da kommt dann
gleich einmal dieser croissant tag um drauf
und dann mache ich den bug ram drumherum
yeah
so den zweiten saisonteil pflegen wir da jetzt
einfach oben drauf die cheesecake masse ist
jetzt nicht so fest dies auch nicht so flüssig
aber trotzdem müsst ihr aufpassen ich wollte
dass man aus und die sind ja schon quasi
vorgeschnitten dadurch dass es ja eigentlich
croissants werden sollten daher auch hier wieder
in der hälfte gleich einmal durchschneiden und am
besten hier auf der arbeitsfläche schon mal
so diese löcher ganz leicht zusammendrücken
dann legen wir das oben drauf dann kommt noch
zimt zucker darauf und dann packen wir es auch
schon ich kann mich ja schon mal die backzeit
verraten 180 grad ober und unterhitze heizt den
ofen schön vor und da braucht brauchen
die tour bus schnitten ca 30 minuten
b
klagen sie auch regelmäßig über
ausgelaufenen teig zu ross schnitten
die nicht funktionieren und einfach zu
postieren frustrierenden ergebnissen
führen setzen sie dem ein ende machen sie
die neue rezeptur von kirchs taurus schnitt
und der brust gehört der vergangenheit
an fertig sind die zur ausschnitten jetzt
wundert euch wahrscheinlich warum stehen hier
zwei bleche ist die kirche wieder so gefräßig
dass sie sich direkt zwei gemacht hat na ja
also das war mein rezept experiment das waren
fällig werde es trotzdem essen sieht halt nur
nicht so schön aus hiess sehr viel ausgelaufen
der teig also der sah diese cheesecake macht
einfach zu flüssig und die backzeit hat nicht
gepasst und das ist meine perfektionierte
variante die euch natürlich hat präsentiert
und ganz wichtig ist dass ihr das komplett
auskühlen das nicht weiß dass es immer die
schönste bart man hat nie geduld nach dem
backen das noch auskühlen zu lassen aber
erst dann wird er fest und erst dann kann
man da auch so richtig schönes stückchen
rausschneiden und später gibt es natürlich
wieder den test mit hamza habenseite noch
nicht probiert also noch gar nicht und ich
bin einfach nur gespannt wie er sich findet
ok hamza wir machen den test ich will einfach nur
so gespannt würde ich aufgeregt weil auch krieg
waren also ich hab's probiert ich bin durchgedreht
euch bezug auf hansa krass ist gar kein ausdruck
also leute gesagt das wird das nächste oder nicht
so trennt das wird der nächste hype da hab ich
so was schadet das nicht probiert mit so wenigen
zutaten und sondern einfach um 20 uhr geht's los
das sind schnitten besser gesagt in drin ist so an
einem schieß cache angenehm also war einfach alles
was ich liebe schießt das ist das nächste ding
olg ist auch so kann das ein bisschen wie sonst
passiert ist so weil ich ja das ist sehr weit ja
heute so richtig weiß also wirklich gespannt hast
unternehmens stück das ist krank der geschmack
als würdest du auch noch zu hoch und auch einem
new york cheesecake beißen nur noch geiler
noch mal auf ein anderes level bis sprachlos
so die feier willkommen schon heftig ohne
whisky schmeckt richtig geil gegen endlich
auf uns zu essen ich habe gerade schon ein stück
ist es schmeckt so heftig also schon das richtig
lecker ich finde sich nicht von dieser welt ich
persönlich beschreiben die sich für das vom kraft
für alle die sich nicht vorstellen können weil
es etwas ganz neues es ist somit eines jahres
kate habe schon bei gästen so und ich weiß nicht
schmeckt oder selber naja das wird jetzt in mode
lahm keine ahnung das ist so geil also für alle
die sich das nicht vorstellen können wir haben
ja unten einmal in diesem ressort teig und
oben nochmal on top und will ist das schon
sehr weich war also gut weiß man kommt super mit
der gabel durch die cheesecake masse ist total
soft und intensiv war nämlich und obendrüber diese
decke die ist für mich für mich ist das highlight
wettgemacht es fehlen die worte ich mal sagen
ich habe richtig 6 so seien so krass wirklich
guten jahren kaufte ich weiß gar nicht wie ich
das definiert wo ist das jetzt auch nicht mehr
so ängstlich oder russland das gibt dann über
über über weltmeister gar nicht hätte ich für
ihn macht einfach machen ich habe gemerkt man
die reaktionen zu krass genau direkte sogar
er hoffe im bild vertreten durch komplett oder
sprachlos und sprache sogar noch ein bisschen
besser ich bin gerade beides ist gleich schlecht
rückt also was soll ich sagen leute wäre das
nicht nach machten selbst schuld also wirklich
ihr verpasst was einfach machen und genießen
ist zunächst mal genau deswegen liebe geht
durch den magen das beste beispiel tap gehören